hello reject nation
I'm Greg Elbe and I'm John Humphrey and
this is genre how's it going everybody
right yeah he's used to you know when
guests are on someone's channel you
introduce them and I forgot to do that
that's all I didn't recognize you
without a hat a mask no yeah yeah well I
recognize you with your face so John
Roca you know from Collider video she
has a lot actually going on under the
schmoes no umbrella I have this all by
memory yes just looking at tax money
yeah sure the outlaw nation thoughts on
anything going on in the world every
week yeah that's my daily oh my weekly
show yeah yeah the top ten list videos
there's a top ten hunger schmoes know
right and also the the cinephiles gets
downloaded podcast you know breakdown of
a great movie and I clearly follow all
these yeah and our friends over at
screen junkies did a special honest
trailer called honest trailers retro TV
themes so nice Michael Bolton and
Friends screen junkies likes when we do
these reactions and I put out a tweet
saying what between a Facebook post what
should i watch for John roca the number
one requested thing with this also keep
our match against top ten yes coming up
real rejects versus top ten in my tummy
up right now or it's out this week yeah
I gotta go there I know some of these
names pablo Machado
they knew that's great but we lost the
MU last year so we're actually gonna get
attention this time maybe we could do
like a fun TV intro like honest theme
songs for some of the nominees
[Music]
oh yay
[Music]
this is brilliant this like the perfect
strangers thing something so brilliant
[Music]
little Cheers action
[Music]
Oh Kenny Loggins now look at that
[Music]
[Applause]
that's brilliant Handmaid's Tale tallit
cool whoa whoa I was not expecting this
oh nice action oh no she was so not
about the mainstream stuff don't you
think so you're doing stuff like this I
haven't seen this yet yeah really yeah
she get questions about it
Mearing Scientology it just gets upset
interviews no yeah she's like it's not
about that you don't understand there's
Michael Bolton
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
oh this is cool
[Music]
that's the biggest mic I've ever seen
[Music]
so it is badass buy this right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow Wow that was epic Wow please help us
in microphone - wait a minute slightly
honors for outstanding short form
variety series oh yeah Brian and sure
I'll cast my vote to see how he pulled
this so hard of the Emmys - that's
Fantas comedy right so guys that was
amazing yeah I thought when they were
doing honors fresh for TV theme so that
was gonna be like making fun of actual
TV shows from like back then this is a
really cool spin they got a bunch of big
names to be a part of here and then
Michael Bolton saw was actually pretty
sweet
I enjoyed the episode of everything the
bullets and touches turns to gold
yeah turn to Valyrian steel hey that guy
can sing anything I've seen him sing
something like when was doing that stuff
for lowly Island that guy can sing
anything his voice is so amazing I
immediately do that song I'm like we're
gonna find this on iTunes I got a song
brilliant yes stranger things who did
that song ownership bidding nataschab a
field that was really cool to their
editing style was great and I like it
when screen junkies mixes up with it
whatever they usually yeah it was kind
of fun seeing like Dan and Andy and
Spencer acting in the beginning of this
like three kids after school yeah it was
just cool the students step more to a
sketch territory this time around yeah
as opposed to just doing a typical
honest trailer hey guys I hope they win
yeah how be nice that recently looking
crazy a mind blowing for YouTube to make
that accomplishment yeah that'd be
insane
maybe next well yes yeah real rejects
right after that come on then and then
oh no I'm just happy being what I am
when you have like a when I wanna
introduce is just like you know
full-fledged yeah three hours show every
day hour
rafi love the elevation sit on the
sybian sit on the severe what I'll sit
on mocking you Tom what the best yeah no
man it's it's it's light its I purposely
chose it to exist in the summer really
yeah I like I was like I gotta be more
relaxed as the outlaw and I found this
thing I'm like this is perfect that is
what I know that's right exactly
I would like you to screen junkies which
is to do it like a rat version of these
kind of things oh yeah there's a lot of
work rappers it used to be famous we'd
love to do it you again see a hammer on
one of these oh yeah now I sum one of
these you know should be great Mark
Ellis
well guys screen junkies that was
amazing man chair say that was one of
the best things I've ever seen you guys
do that was fantastic I really got a
major kick it off and I love that they
chose to do the songs and style of other
familiar TV yeah themes as well like
they had the Dawson's Creek one in there
yeah Paula Cole what the hell yeah Brian
McKnight always nice to see you
subscribe to screen junkies you can
subscribe to the real rejects if you
want it really does nothing for the
channel you can click the notification
bell you won't get notified don't worry
about it
dad John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram you might follow him who knows
but more importantly off the top of my
head you should follow you know John
roca at the rokka rokka says on social
media you know he has that schmoes know
shows that I watch know that one a [ __ ]
or like top 10 and his podcast
signifying else you you should go do
that that's more important and than
anything else we have to offer today Wow
I thank you so much probably know that's
not true at all yeah you guys are
fantastic please subscribe I don't care
if he says it doesn't over the channel
subscribe anyway the real rejects are
awesome I love being on YouTube dead